♪
>> Sean: YOUR DEMOCRATIC
FRIENDS, YOUR CORRUPT MEDIA,
THEY HAVE BEEN RUSHING TO
SPIN AND DEFLECT FROM THE IG
REPORTS, DEVASTATING
REVELATIONS.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
COULD NOT HAVE BEEN MORE
CLEAR ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE
SAYS THERE WAS NO CONSPIRACY
HERE.
WITHIN THE FBI.
>> I EXPECTED THE SLEDGE
HAMMER.
WE JUST GOT THE SAME KIND OF
HAMMER YOU USED TO NAIL IN A
PAINTING ON THE WALL.
I DIDN'T -- I WAS SURPRISED
AT HOW MILD IT WAS.
>> NO POLITICAL BIAS
INFLUENCED THE
DECISION-MAKING AT EITHER
THE FBI OR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
>> DECISIONS DESCRIBED IN
THE REPORT ALL HELPED DONALD
TRUMP WIN OUT ELECTION.
ALL THE ERRORS WERE IN
TRUMP'S FAVOR.
>> ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
JUST LIARS POLITICAL HACKS,
JUST SPINNING AWAY.
THEY DON'T TELL YOU THE
TRUTH AND THEY DON'T CARE.
REACTION FOX NEWS SECURITY
ANALYST DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JASON
CHAFFETZ.
DR. GORKA, START WITH YOU.
YOUR REACTION IN ALL OF
THIS.
>> WELL, DISGUSTED AT ALL
THE DETAILS OF THE LOW LEVEL
STUFF, YOU KNOW, BUYING
SOMEBODY A MALE TO GET
SOMEBODY A LALE TO GET
SOMEBODY A LEGE TO GET
SOMEBODY A LEGALTO GET
SOMEBODY A MEGALTO GET
SOMEBODY A MEAALTO GET
SOMEBODY A MEALLTO GET
SOMEBODY A MEAL TO GET A
LEAK FROM THEM AT THE FBI.
AT THE END OF THE DAY NO
COVERUP.
NO THERE THERE.
PEOPLE PERP WALKED OUT OF
THE FBI AND DUONG FOR SLOW
ROLLING AND UNDERMINING THE
INVESTIGATION OF A REAL
CRIME, HILLARY, AND TRYING
TO UNDERMINE A POLITICAL
CANDIDATE AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION, DONALD
TRUMP.
>> Sean: AT THE END OF THE
DAY, AND WHEN YOU LOOK
ESPECIALLY AT THE TEXT
MESSAGES AND REVELATIONS
CONGRESSMAN CHAFFETZ I LOOK
AT THAT TIME AND THIS IS
WHAT I SEE.
I SEE PEOPLE AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS, FBI, DOJ DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
PREVENT HILLARY FROM GOING
TO JAIL THEY DID NOT ENFORCE
THE RULE OF LAW WITH HER.
LITERALLY TOOK A SLEDGE
HAMMER AND STARTED THIS
WITCH-HUNT INVESTIGATION
AGAINST TRUMP AND THEY NEVER
STOPPED SWINGING THE SLEDGE
HAMMER, WHICH TELLS ME WE
DON'T HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW UNDER THIS FBI
DIRECTOR, UNDER THAT LAST
ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK THIS IS JUSTTH
BEGINNING.
NOT THE END.
>> NO.
LOOK, I REALLY DO BELIEVE
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
WHITE WASHING OF WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN HILLARY
CLINTON'S EMAIL SERVER.
THERE WAS NOT A SERIOUS
INVESTIGATION THERE THEY
NEVER WENT AFTER.
THEY DIDN'T -- THE REPORT
POINTS OUT THAT THEY NEVER
WENT AND GOT ALL OF THE
ACTUAL HARDWARE THAT WAS OUT
THERE.
HILLARY CLINTON WAS OUT
THERE, YOU KNOW, DESTROYING
ALL THE EVIDENCE.
THERE WAS NEVER A SERIOUS
INVESTIGATION FROM THE FBI.
AND I DISAGREE WITH
SEBASTIAN GORKA.
THIS IS THE PREQUELL.
HAVE YOU GOT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE IG ALSO HAS AN
INVESTIGATION GOING IN TO
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
FISA ABUSE INVESTIGATION.
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN.
I DON'T WANT TO GO THERE.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
HILLARY CLINTON SHOULD HAVE
BEEN IN JAIL.
IF THEY TREATED HER LIKE
KRISTIAN SAUCIER, SHE WOULD
HAVE BEEN INDICTED.
YOU HAD ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT TONIGHT
PROTECTING HER.
PREVENTING HER FROM GETTING
THE TREATMENT EVERY OTHER
AMERICAN WOULD GET.
>> THAT'S HIGHLIGHTED IN
THIS REPORT.
WE NOW HAVE HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF
DOCUMENTATION, THE
MANIPULATION OF THE MEDIA,
IT WAS AN INDICTMENT OF THE
MEDIA AS WELL.
I THINK THE REFERRAL TO THE
OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY WILL BEAR
FRUIT.
THAT TAKES TIME TO PLAY OUT.
GIVEN THE RULES THAT THEY
HAVE TO DO.
>> Sean: SHOULD MILLER
>> Sean: SHOULD HILLER
>> Sean: SHOULD HILLARY BE
CHARGED?
>> SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CHARGED A LONG TIME AGO.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: THEY PROTECTED HER.
NOW THEY ARE GOING AFTER
TRUMP THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
PROTECTED HER.
>> HOROWITZ IS TOO CLOSE TO